E aí
[Música]
Bom primeiramente bom dia boa tarde e
boa noite independente do horário que
você vai estar escutando as conversas eu
te chamo para conhecer um pouco do meu
trabalho e um pouco do meu mundo
mas primeiro eu quero te convidar a
pensar no mundo hipotético no mundo onde
que todos têm acesso à informação onde
que não existe a uma taxa de 59 por
cento de jovem em favelas que não tem
acesso a um computador a internet onde
que também
todos têm acesso a tecnologias do mundo
atual e onde as oportunidades não sejam
diferente para quem é da favela e duas
fotos
e atualmente nós utilizamos uma fala que
o conhecimento está na Palma de nossas
mãos e nossa smartphones tablet com
nossos computadores
que só não aprende quem não quer
é mas realmente essencial devemos levar
isso ao pé da letra
é através da minha vida profissional e
pessoal eu posso te provar que não é bem
assim
Olá eu sou um dos milhões de jovens
desse país que teve sua vida impactaria
diretamente pelo poder transformador da
educação
a educação e impossibilitou conquistar
coisas e o lugares que eu nunca imaginei
ser possíveis
a mais durante toda a minha caminhada
pessoal e profissional a educação teve
uma parceira que caminhou com ela lá do
lado que foi a tecnologia e a tecnologia
não me foi apresentada com laboratório
de última geração na minha escola um
supercomputador na minha casa até porque
eu era duro e não tinha grana para isso
Ela é bem fácil a tecnologia foi
apresentada pelo meu pai quando ele me
deu Meu primeiro videogame falou filho a
partir daqui a com você
bom então quando o meu controle de
videogame que brava eu tinha duas opções
hoje não tava dinheiro para comprar um
novo
ou aprende a consertar eu escolhi a
segunda opção porque não tinha dinheiro
e assim eu aprendi eletrônica na
curiosidade isso virou um vício porque
eu não parei só no controle de videogame
eu quando eu ia para a rua e vi ali
Eletro eletro portáteis
eletroeletrônicos no lixo dos meus
vizinhos ali nas ruas do complexo alemão
do Morro do Adeus eu pegava levava para
minha casa desmontava e tentava
consertar é porque a tecnologia tem
desse barato ela nos torna seres
curiosos nos dá uma abertura um novo
mundo onde a gente quer constantemente
saber o como o porquê eo para quê das
coisas e dessa forma eu aprendi
eletrônica muito novo através da
curiosidade no ano de 2018 eu fui
fundador de um laboratório Maker na
minha faculdade
É sim fazer a mínima ideia do que era
essa tal de Cultura mídia hoje eu posso
falar para vocês que essa cultura Ney
outra make aportuguesando nada mais é do
que a cultura tu fazedor utilizando o
conceito de básicos de marcenaria
eletrônica robótica em arte
É nesse laboratório eu fui apresentado
uma ferramenta
tecnologia que hoje é o que motiva a
fazer tudo o que eu faço eu fui
apresentado uma a uma impressora 3D a
impressora 3D da faculdade era de uma
marca gringa chamada makerbot quando
olhei ela foi amor à primeira vista eu
falei eu vou te comprar
eu entrei no site e ela custava de 15 a
18 horas às dezoito mil reais no site da
mega bot isso em 2018 Oi e eu falei que
tu tá não vou te comprar com que eu ia
gastar uma impressora dessa dava para
comprar um Fiat Uno
Ah
mas também eu pensei se um gringo pode
fazer uma parada dessa eu também posso
a e nesse momento da minha vida entra
essa questão de um conhecimento está ali
para todos na Palma de nossas mãos o que
realmente estava
é através de vídeos do YouTube fóruns
nacionais e internacionais de sites eu
consegui armazenar todo o conhecimento
para a produção dessas máquinas
bom e depois de seis meses já tinha
absorvido toda a teoria
a Beleza bora produzir mas eu não tinha
e ferramentas para colocar esse meu
conhecimento em prática
bom então eu fui utilizar o que eu tinha
mais acesso que era sucatas eletrônicas
e eu fui conseguir essa sucata numa
cooperativa de catadores onde que a
culpa mas onde eu fui aprender sobre
reciclagem sobre economia circular e
nessa cooperativa eu conseguisse insumos
e depois de 680 reais e dez centavos eu
fiz a minha primeira impressora 3D a
é utilizando sucata nesse momento
encaramos uma realidade que outros
jovens nas mesmas situações que eu de
Biotipo social encaram que tem que às
vezes em cada dez vezes mais obstáculos
e dificuldades para Alcançar a meta que
ele tanto deseja e
e foi nesse momento então que eu encarei
o meu primeiro Abismo social e
tecnológico onde eu vi que eu queria ter
acesso e hoje teria Muitas dificuldades
para ter
e no ano de 2019 eu fiz a minha primeira
palestra e foi um colégio público
chamado Padre Manoel da Nóbrega
nesse Colégio eu fiz uma parece de 20
minutos para 100 alunos numa sala e
fiquei duas horas respondendo as
perguntas desses alunos A grande maioria
das perguntas eram o tio eu consigo
fazer isso eu tenho capacidade de fazer
como você fez eu tenho capacidade de
aprender o meu pai ele um dia vai
conseguir botar um negócio desse dentro
da minha casa
foi aí que eu vi que a minha vida não
era fazer a impressora barata era
compartilhamento de conhecimento e a
partir dessa dor afoguei-me em Startup
aí fio a em fio ela nasceu o único
objetivo
democratização de tecnologias em favelas
onde que o objetivo principal é
transformar isso fortalece verdadeiras
ou a câmeras Onde vamos ver jovens
pretos e favelados melhorando a
realidade local de suas comunidades e
assim também que se descobrindo e
criando um novo negócio
o início também da questão dos jovens
que ele sempre aprender comigo eu
desenvolvi uma apostila de forma
simplificada onde eles aprendem a
construir sua própria impressora 3D e
assim todos jovens que queiram aprender
eu dou esse material dessa forma eu fui
democratizando o acesso à tecnologia
Oi e eu cheguei no ponto onde hoje três
ONGs no Rio de Janeiro tem as minhas
impressoras onde elas são utilizadas
como ferramenta de mudança social em
aulas de robótica em aulas de tecnologia
para jovens e crianças
mais cara se a cultura Maker é tão
querido eu assim porque não levar ela
para dentro da favela e eu pensava isso
então eu resolvi fazer uma pesquisa de
campo onde eu entrevistei 30 jovens
aleatórios no Complexo do Alemão e o
Chile perguntei aí jovem tu sabe que a
cultura Maker os 30 me responderam não
eu sei que a grande maioria de vocês que
estou assistindo essa palestra deve
estar se perguntando caramba todas a
gente posta serem negativas Mas é porque
provavelmente vocês tem a convivência
com a cultura Maker no colégio dos seus
filhos ou nos trabalho de vocês mas
esses jovens estão inseridos na é uma
questão social que ele dentro da favela
então eles não tinham a cultura Maker em
seu cotidiano
e e e era uma resposta que eu já sabia
que ia ser negativa porque
eu fui professor de uma escola de alto
padrão da zona sul do Rio de Janeiro e
nessa escola os meus alunos a partir dos
6 anos de idade tinhas é só um notebook
cada um internet na escola toda
laboratório de robótica informática
laboratório Maker e aulas de programação
com seis anos de idade sendo que os
jovens da minha comunidade eles mal
tinham acesso aos computadores da escola
que funcionava ou na internet banda
larga um computador e suas casos
e essa é uma realidade que parece ser
muito dura e ser escutada mas para que o
morador do Rio de Janeiro igual a mim a
gente convive com esse antes e depois do
túnel que são choque de realidades que o
Rio de Janeiro tem esse choque sociais
assustadores em pleno século 21
Oi e eu tive dois grandes pensadores
time ajudar a pensar como chegar se a
tecnologia esse jovem um deles foi meu
avô Israel o meu avô ele só estudou até
a 3ª série e ele veio da roça de Minas
Gerais para trabalhar no Rio e o meu avô
sempre me ensinou que
através de educação eu ia chegar aonde
eu quisesse e conquistar o que eu
quisesse
é um outro Pensador foi Paulo Freire que
me ensinou que é que ensinar era
entender uma realidade para depois de
transformá-la o Ou seja eu queria botar
a goela abaixo daquele jovens uma
matéria totalmente eletrizado por mês
usado e da forma errada eu tinha que
aprender a ler a realidade da qual eu
mesmo estava inserido
bom então repito a pergunta para esse
jovens aí cara tu sabe o que é gambiarra
a resposta foi positiva todo mundo
falando pô meu pai é fera meu avô é
Mestre minha casa é feita com gambiarra
por aí que eu entendi o poder
transformador da gambiarra para mim e
para outros jovens dentro da favela
porque para eles a gambiarra é uma
ferramenta e de inovação tecnológica e
resolução de problemas a baixo custo
o japo dicionário da língua portuguesa
gambiarra é um gato de luz uma ligação
elétrica mal feita um pedaço de fio com
uma tomada em um bocal de lâmpada mais
pessoas com algum eu a gambiarra é uma
ferramenta tecnológica que pode ser
utilizada para uma transformação social
depois que eu comecei a levar a palavra
da gambiarra adiante ensinar os jovens
da minha comunidade tecnologia através
dessa linguagem mais informal e favelada
eles começaram entender tecnologia que
uma outra visão com outros olhos
Oi e esse jovem começar e se interessar
por tecnologia
Há muitos Ou seja eu não tinha que levar
o mundo para dentro da favela eu tinha
que mostrar para eles que a favela é um
mundo onde que se você der as
ferramentas para que esses jovens se
desenvolva dali de dentro vai sair o
próprio o próximo cientista um próximo
astronauta porque a favela é um lugar
altamente inventivo e a gambiarra
proporcionar isso
é o que eu quero dizer que to twice
O que podemos sim transformar educação
nesse país através de uma visão mais
clara de metodologia de ensino de vez de
ensinar um ensino que é elitizado que
tem escolas de alto padrão que é
totalmente ali com termos em inglês
porque não adaptar à cultura da favela
para ensinar tecnologia
bom então eu faço um convite a você que
é dono de empresa
empresário dono de grandes corporações
que vocês possam participar dessa
mudança dando uma chance para o jovem da
favela e te mostrar do que a fazer é
capaz
é porque a favela vai surpreender vocês
e a gambiarra hoje para mim é onde me
colocou no lugar que eu estou como
Engenheiro como empreendedor e como
professor
oi e ela pode ajudar outros jovens assim
e
seguiu o mesmo caminho que eu vou seguir
os caminhos que eles quiserem através de
uma coisa chamada oportunidade
bom então eu agradeço muito essa
oportunidade de estar falando com vocês
e termina minha fala com Vivo uma
educação inclusiva para todos
viva uma tecnologia para todos
viva Paulo Freire e viva a gambiarra
tamo junto e até a próxima